[Applause]
for the last four years
brexit defined our nation 12 months ago
it seemed inconceivable that the issue
like these crowds would disperse
but while protests have ceased an
end-of-year deadline to work out our new
relationship with the EU remains in
force could it really be done without
all the shouting why is the end of year
deadline quite so important given the
massive scale of the pandemic crisis
that we're facing if the reality is
progress has been made and we're
confident we can get there and look we
do face a challenge with coronavirus but
they'll be damage to the economy we want
to bounce back but actually one of the
things we know that businesses would
like some certainty of no knowing that
this has been concluded I think the
country wants some certainty and we're
elected on that basis the familiar
sticking points fishing the northern
island border and whether or not to
follow some EU rules haven't gone away
and today we also began trade talks in
parallel with the us who want British
access for their agricultural sector
it's inconceivable their UK would have
more bargaining power with the United
States then for instance the EU would
have help from number Ten's point of
view maybe it's just easier to do the
negotiations like this without the
shouting and the protests and the breath
has focused on every dot and cover think
of the disruption that we were so
worried about just a few months ago what
does that even look like in a world
where nothing is normal
brexit was meant to be the biggest
one-off change since the Second World
War and then something else got there
first
you negotiations may be somewhat easier
when they're not center stage for the
media and there's less sort of obsessive
focus on every statement in every
development talks by phone and video
link rather than face to face
given brexit is a form of social
distancing from Europe maybe it is the
most appropriate way forward for now
Sam Cote Sky News